Good morning.
My name's Bill Fudge, and this is my granddaughter Bridget.
Uh, Bridget came to know the Lord when she was much younger,
but didn't understand about baptism,
but through a close friend's, uh, nearing death
and then passing away in January,
she started reading her Bible
and came across a verse that spoke to her
when she went to church.
She heard the preacher preach on that verse.
And then later that week, the same, uh,
different friend spoke to her using that same verse, come
to me and I will give you rest.
And so she's been close drawing closer to the Lord,
reading her scripture daily
and realized that she needed to be baptized.
And so today she comes to you to be baptized.
Bridget, I have one question.
Have you accepted the Lord as your Lord and Savior? Yes.
Then it's my privilege, my granddaughter
and sister in faith to baptize you in the name
of the Father, the Son, and the Holy Spirit.
Stand up.